une des principales préoccupations des
français actuellement et l'accès aux
soins pourquoi parce qu'effectivement
depuis trente ans il ya de moins en
moins de médecins toutes les majorités
de droite ou de gauche ont voulu gérer
ce qu'on appelait le trou de la sécu en
forme - médecins moines affirment ils ça
c'est la première chose deuxième chose
effectivement la pratique médicale les
médecins de n'exerce plus comme vous
pouvez exercer à 30 ans ils ne veulent
plus travailler dix heures par jour ils
ne veulent plus travailler de manière
isolée c'est pour ça que depuis quatre
ans on a pris sept ans baisieux la
principale c'est la fin du numerus
clausus maintenant ce qui reste à faire
c'est faire en sorte de rendre attractif
et la médecine libérale en levant les
contraintes et en rendre plus attractifs
les territoires et c'est pour ça que le
principe c'est de de montrer aux jeunes
médecins
qu'il est agréable facile et intéressant
de travailler dans des territoires
ruraux et il faut rapprocher
effectivement les facultés de médecine
d'été des territoires ruraux j'en
exemple simple pendant leurs études des
étudiants lyonnais ont pu faire des
gardes en ardèche et des gardes auprès
des pompiers ils y allaient passer dans
leurs soirées leur week-end ils ont
découvert ce département ils ont fait
leurs réseaux au sein de ce département
ce qui fait que aujourd'hui il ya treize
jeunes médecins issus des facultés de
lyon qui sont allés s'installer en
ardèche parce que durant les études on a
pu leur faire découvrir un territoire
donc notre position au niveau du bourg
démocrate ces deux de ne pas contraindre
contrairement au programme que peut
proposer la droite et à gauche mais
c'est d'inciter les jeunes médecins
c'est de lever les contraintes et donner
plus d'attractivité à l'exercice libéral
de la médecine et plus d'attrait et de
faire donc connaître ces territoires aux
gets de temps